(music)
- Vaccine passes being
mandatory were being
debated in the US and
other Western countries
even before the first COVID-19
vaccines were available.
Here in Italy, the
government has introduced
one of the toughest in the west,
requiring all workers to prove
they have been vaccinated,
have tested negative in
the previous 48 hours,
or have recently recovered from COVID-19.
(crowd cheering)
While most Italians are in favor
of requiring the green
pass to be able to work,
implementation hasn't
been without pushback.
People here in Milan
and other parts of Italy
have been protesting against
the green pass mandate.
(crowd protesting)
The day after the implementation,
some 15,000 protesters took
to the streets here in Milan
with some violence included.
A small but growing resistance
to the past in Italy,
gives an idea of what the
Biden administration could
be up against as it
gets ready to introduce
its own vaccine mandate.
- Labor department is gonna
soon be issuing an emergency
rule for companies with a
hundred or more employees
to implement vaccination
requirements among their workforce.
- The COVID-19 health pass,
which is known as the
green pass here in Italy,
includes an individual
QR code for each person.
It can be shown on a printed page
or somebody's mobile phone.
Italy has required the green
pass since early August
for indoor activities
like going to restaurants,
bars, museums, and theaters.
So people have had time to get used to it,
but the workplace requirement
has sparked a heated debate.